is already going on the point is how to
stop it and i think that the agreement
that was reached misc some 10 days ago
is the only option we have to see the
conflict getting to an end in the east
of Ukraine and now all our efforts are
in implementing and making sure that it
is implemented on a particular on
disparities site but it will settle
basically on president Putin's terms
he'll still have Crimea he'll still have
large parts of southeastern Ukraine
under his control now the point is
making the conflict stop in the east of
Ukraine because people are still dying
and this is the priority not that's the
first that not only the ceasefire not
only for the international community not
only for Europe but for the government
gives this is the priority number one
and we have to be careful and listen to
their priorities first then the
withdrawal of the weapons this is going
to be the second step for which we will
need to have monitors on the ground with
much more access more means and then all
the path that has been agreed but we
have to have the starting point with the
ceasefire and withdrawals of but it's
not credible is it to roll back Crimea
for example I hope it is I hope it is
because you know the dangerous think
about this is not only the people dying
on the ground but also the fact that
basic principles of international law
has been violated and this is dangerous
not only for Europe or from Ukraine
dangerous also for the entire
international community so the
annexation of Crimea is something the
European Union will never recognize what
about the possible entry of Ukraine or
part of Ukraine into European Union has
that been dropped by the treaty every
country that is on European territory
has the right or the possibility sooner
or later to ask to join that I mean
that's not the matter was it has not
been on the agenda in the last year's it
is not on the agenda now what we have
with Ukraine is an association agreement
which means a strong partnership that
allows the European Union to support
Ukraine in its reforms and is what we're
doing economic reforms social reforms
internal institutional reforms that are
also key to implementing the the Minsk
agreement somehow what we also need to
do is to make Ukraine success for the
Ukrainians because we don't have to
forget that apart from the conflict that
is going on in this the major concern
the major dream also the cleaning people
is to have a different country that is
working better without corruption with a
business environment with the full full
modern functioning state and our
European role is to make it possible how
worried are you though that Russia is
attempting to win friends in Greece and
ferment its minority communities in the
Baltics I mean it doesn't appear that
maybe a ceasefire but it's not an end of
hostilities from Navarro CA you know our
strength as Europe has been our unity
and I am more than confident that we're
keeping that unit you will have
discussions within member states among
member states outside of Europe we will
have a discussion about what kind of
strategy we need to have and to develop
towards Russia but I am confident on the
fact that when it comes to violation of
serenity and in territorial integrity of
a country Europe will stand united and
if necessary much tougher sanctions
sanctions always there ready to be
adopted to be lifted and the basic
principle has always been from the very
beginning that we take the decisions
only on the situation on the ground
situation on the ground improves the
sanctions can be lifted partially lifted
situation on the ground doesn't improve
or get worse they can be kept or added
new measures new measures are always
ready but the priority here is not only
concentrating on our counter measures if
things go wrong but how we can
contribute to make things go better and
in this respect what we have started to
do since now many ways is to work in
Kiev with our people in Kiev together
with the monitors together with the OSC
to make sure that implementation
is made possible on the ground do you
think Europe needs to do more to protect
its borders not necessarily people
coming in where there are problems but
from people getting out I mean we're
having great problems in this country
France as well are people going to join
is is there anything that we've done
there's a lot that can be done on
different levels on the interior level
ministers of interior minister of
justice can do a lot when it comes to
countering recruitment and
radicalization I think of the work we
can do on internet I think work we can
do on the working with Imams and the
mosques on the work we do on integration
of different communities also under
control of the passengers on flights for
sure but then there is also another work
we can do with the partners we have
around the region because we need to
intensify and we're doing that our
cooperation on security and exchange of
information finally had a lightning tour
of London and Britain today do you
understand why there seems to be such a
movement in this country to leave the
European Union you know UK is a key
member state for European Union I look
at foreign policy UK is one of the
countries that has somehow been leading
Europe in looking outwards and taking
the responsibilities in the world it
would be almost impossible to imagine
any kind of foreign policy of the
European Union without UK so my plea to
UK people I used to stay staying does
not mean forgetting about national
interests and focusing on the European
interest European interest is serving
the national interests better and there
are certain number of things we can only
do together think of your current think
of Russia the impact we have on Russia
through the sanctions is possible
because we are together United single
member states alone would have much less
relevant impact on all the crises we
have around us we have to be respectful
of national interests we have to find
European ways
observing that interests in the best
possible way but we need to be together
in order to face all the challenges we
have no member state no country alone
can solve any of the problems we have
around